ils vont gérer maintenant le chef de
bord c'est l'heure du rassemblement
matinal pour les militaires de l'unité
spéciale mixte des forces armées
centrafricaines face aux troupes
le capitaine les weight donne ses
dernières instructions avant le départ
en patrouille dans la ville de bouard
petite localité située dans le nord
ouest du pays
constituée d'anciens rebelles de
policiers de militaires
cette formation a été mise en place dans
le cadre de l'accord de paix signé en
février 2010 9 entre le gouvernement et
14 groupes armés pour l'officier chargé
de l'encadrer la cohésion entre les
différents éléments restent difficiles à
trouver
la cohabitation départ c'est un peu
difficile chemin faisant une semaine
deux semaines un mois plus tard les gens
ils sont habitués il sent même dans les
mêmes dans toi et moi gens semblent ils
font le sport ensemble ils font les
cours ensemble depuis là présentement il
ya pas assez de soucis
parmi les recrues de l'unité faouzia qui
est issu d'un groupe rebelle local
elle fait partie des premiers
combattants démobilisés à avoir intégré
cette formation il faut travailler
proprement et remplir chaque mission
on est bien avec les autres on s'entend
bien les instructeurs nous apprennent à
surmonter la peur et à oublier notre
ancienne ville
c'est très bien ici particularité de
l'unité spéciale mixte ses membres ne
peuvent pas utiliser d'armes à feu les
soldats sont donc munis de couteaux et
de longs bâtons en bois pour ses
patrouilles l'objectif reste avant tout
de rassurer les populations
quand je les vois passer je suis heureux
parce qu'ils ont oublié leur colère pour
opter pour la cohésion qu'on s'aime
comme une famille d'autres fois ça
montre qu'il n'ya plus d'histoire de
musulmans ou quoi que ce soit mais que
tout centrafricain doit participer à la
reconstruction du pays
toujours en phase expérimentale l'unité
de boire doit servir de modèle avant la
création de formation similaire dans le
reste du pays
ce sera l'un des objectifs à tenir pour
le prochain chef d'état centrafricain le
premier tour de la présidentielle se
déroulera le 27 décembre prochain